Gale king is in Philadelphia this
morning where she had an interview with
Starbucks executive chairman Howard
Schultz about the company's plan to
train its workers to avoid bias Gayle
joins us now from inside that Starbucks
store and Gail I know you asked him to
about whether he saw that video of those
two men being arrested Norah you're
right you know me very well video
showing that arrest has now been seen
worldwide
so we asked Howard Schultz about his
reaction to that now infamous footage
and the issue of unconscious racial bias
I first saw it on Friday I couldn't
believe it I was I was sick to my
stomach I was embarrassed I was ashamed
this is the antithesis of the values and
culture of everything Starbucks stands
for it stands where you founded this
company to foster human experience yes
so this was an Anatomy tonight however
it's undeniable when you look at the
tape that we are responsible that I
personally am responsible and we need to
address it with transparency and honesty
and we we all got on a plane and came to
Philadelphia we all who is that Kevin
Johnson myself you've said your team
yeah the senior team and I think this
was a galvanizing moment for the entire
company we have issues in our company
that we need to recognize and in
recognizing that we decided we're going
to close every single store at great
expense yeah for retraining but it won't
won't stop there we have been on a
journey to talk about race in America
it's a very difficult subject raised to
talking about race makes people very
uncomfortable
but you say let's go there I think in
other country has systemic issues
certainly there's a great divide in the
country it's a great device race in
America I'm not saying that Starbucks in
any way has an anecdote to fix it but
perhaps we can use this moment as a
healing moment for our company and in
doing so given the fact that we serve so
many millions of people and employ
hundreds of thousands of people we can
use this as an opportunity to educate
you just said when you looked at the
tape you were heartsick but did you
think it was an isolated incident and
I'm asking that because now I'm hearing
more and more stories from people I know
strangers on the street are saying you
know what I had an incident at Starbucks
I'm not surprised to hear this I think
it's possible that given the level of
unconscious bias that exists in America
and how systemic this problem is in the
country that this is not an isolated
situation and if it's not we will deal
with every one of them I want to
personally apologize for anyone who has
ever felt anything other than respect
and dignity in our stores and I've said
publicly for years at regardless of the
color skin your sexual orientation your
politics
you are welcome at Starbucks what does
Starbucks plan to do to make people more
accountable for these
we're reviewing every single policy and
we're communicating directly with our
people so that they understand that
calling 9-1-1 because to
african-american young men are sitting
in our stores it's absolutely the wrong
thing to do what is the definition of
trespassing in Starbucks I mean people
come in here all the time they're some
of them are eating Starbucks things some
of them aren't what is a definition of
trespassing this is a place where
everybody comes nobody should be asked
to leave Starbucks now this is the third
place between home and work we serve
millions of people so I don't want to
ask anyone to leave now there are
certain situations where people are not
acting appropriately either they're
homeless or they're they have mental
health issues that was not the case here
this was absolutely not the case here so
we want to be an inviting welcoming
place for everyone Howard Schultz told
me there is no textbook on how to handle
something like this he said really all
you can do is operate on instinct and
heart he said it was deeply personal and
I felt that I felt really that his pain
was palpable when I was talking to him
today he's arranging now a meeting
between the manager and the two young
black men and I said do the young black
men want to meet with her yes and she
wants to meet with him with them she's
been getting death threats they're
concerned about her safety but Howard
says this is not a one-off he intends to
see this through so back to you guys in
the studio I also have to tell you this
I tried very hard to get Howard to come
to the table yesterday because I thought
it would be great to have him in the
studio and I think I might have pushed
too hard because finally just said Gail
I cannot do it I have all these meetings
in Philadelphia I'm happy to talk to you
all but I cannot come to New York so I
was delighted he agreed to meet with us
in a Starbucks because that was an issue
too few people can say no to you Gail
but you know aside from that being the
right moral decision on his part is the
right business decision - in Wall Street
it's rewarding him for that Gail thank
you